[Music]
from legendary actor Clint Eastwood who
reinvented himself as a director debater
what do you mean shut
up an absolute horn dog I'm up for
anything my
[Music]
turn comes a grand that movie about the
thing seniors love to hate other
cultures look I don't know what a crime
looks like loud
neighbors and whatever's playing on
cable news you see Hannity last night
the kids identify as kitty cats now
crapping themselves in a litter box I
swear this country's going down the
drain American
Sniper welcome to a film set in the
Middle East so queue up that call to
prayer give me an orange tined shot of
the Sun and just a little bit of that
wobbly heat vision effect you know there
that's it now we're in a Middle East
movie as we return to America's naughty
aies war on terror where 15 Saudis
trained in Afghanistan did 9/11 so we
blew up let me check my map here Iraq in
a film that tries to focus on the mental
tolls of War but since all he brought
was a gun everything turns into a
Target
that was gnarly watch Bradley Cooper Go
full wet sausage mode to play real life
Texan Chris Kyle a Navy SEAL who lived
by the code of Team America World Police
they three types of people in this world
dicks sheep
wolves and sheep dogs but since Brad's a
stock broker's son from the Philly
suburbs he'll crank the ye-ho up past
hog heaven with a big old belt buckle
Longhorn cap and traditional Texas M
call hands in the air little lady in the
role that convince beps he can only make
Oscar bait from now on or voice of
raccoon for lots of money
oh yeah and even that's got a little
bity these
[Music]
days come on Brad you can still make
comedies Adam Scott doesn't have to take
all your old characters you look amazing
even better than before are you ready to
condense a 500 page biography into two
disorienting hours hope so with a few
short minutes spent on meeting courting
and marrying his wife his PTSD getting
cured off
camera I am so happy that I've got my
husband back then abruptly dying
offscreen because they got to make room
for what the audience paid to see the
USA kicking
out and Bradley Cooper playing with his
job enemy sniper located grid we're back
Romeo oh yeah oh oh gently gently real
sensitive now ooh yeah now I'm ready to
shoot was that a crew dick joke sorry I
just watched American Sniper oh we're
just picking our dicks here man ladies
and gentl listen up one Blow from a
single man he blew
men any single you know that's that's a
way to my heart squirrel squirrel
squirrel where the are you nut oh
they're going for good sir are you tired
of American exceptionalism cuz it's the
greatest country on Earth and I do
everything I can to protect it then get
ready for Chris Kyle exceptionalism your
dad he's a hero that takes his already
wild true story and TS on a few Call of
Duty levels for good
measure
where he doesn't miss a single shot in
combat or chow and damn it food fight
teaches Marines how to do their
jobs what's that me and is 100%
convinced America can't win without him
let somebody else go yeah yeah I
couldn't live myself yeah well you find
a way but in this film he's right and we
wouldn't want sooner if his dang wife
wasn't on his back at home how much help
do you need with a plastic baby anyway
just give it plastic milk meet the only
enemy brave enough to cross barrels with
Chris
Mustafa an enemy sniper who gets one
mention in the book but the movie turns
into his arch nemesis you complete with
his own intelligence Network stop his
got his peers out signature Nikes and
trick shot video side hustle that's a
sniper recording his kills that's Musta
he sells that on the street as the film
gets hyperfocused on their madeup
rivalry they're going to pay for what
they did to you even if it means turning
Chris into someone who risk his squad's
life on a hudge Hold Your Fire you'll
expose us all it's him oh it's him but
whatever now that the only guy in Iraq
who can shoot is dead the war is over I
guess I don't know Wikipedi it mission
accomplished so join America's Least
detail oriented filmmaker who's
definitely not just trying to crank out
films and time to make it home for Blue
Bloods clinty Woods films have very
happy companies and he comes in under
scheduled and he comes in under budget
every single time for a film about one
man's quest to keep his brother safe and
Liberate the good people of Iraq from
their evil oppressors not this guy
though or
her or him definitely not him oh he
seems nice wait no not him
either not her not him not that kid not
them all right I guess every single
Iraqi in the film is evil huh light them
up boys get some
starring super Cooper sniper no sniping
terrorists win drill baby drill an
actual seal they made into a coward for
no reason hurah this place hurah mind
Haunter and doll of
Duty vet hard American
camper wow I can't believe they're just
throwing the Punisher in this if you
haven't watch the Netflix shows how are
you supposed to even know what's
happening hey screen junkies we just saw
that Chris don't miss but is Chris Kyle
the best sniper in cinema history we had
ourselves an old-fashioned snipe off in
an allnew episode of BU the numbers best
movie sniper adjust your knob until
you've got a clear shot at the Box on
the right then pull that Mouse trigger
to watch
now congrats sagaa on getting a fairer
share now let's make some me
movies epic voice guy has to think about
his whole life before he reads the
comments I am the master of the baking
watch